[Music]
thank you
first up Bloomberg's Adrian Wooldridge
writes this week's cover story about the
death of meritocracy a new Progressive
aristocracy is taking over Britain and
America he says to explain he joins me
now alongside journalist Peter Hitchens
Adrian Peter thanks for joining me on
spectator TV Adrian you write the cover
for this week's magazine where you look
at a new kind of attack on meritocracy
what do you say I say I sent you this
that the in the in the pre-modern world
we had a society which was hierarchical
and in which people were judged
according to their membership of groups
rather than their individual abilities
um so if you're a woman or if you're a
member of the lower classes you were
ipso facto subordinate and we had since
then since about the middle of the 19th
century but before that we had a liberal
Revolution which said no you must judge
people as individuals rather than as
members of groups and you should promote
them according to their individual
merits uh rather than their group
identities
um and the most
um fulfilling version of that was the
idea of meritocracy and I think for a
long time we had this idea of
meritocracy broadening and deepening
um and particularly after the second
world war we had a sort of period in
which meritocracy was in many ways the
ruling ideology of the world then we had
the left which had done a great deal to
promote meritocracy turning against the
idea of meritocracy saying that it
perverted socialism from an idea ideal
of equality to one of uh competition
um and that you should get rid of these
awful institutions like the 11 plus and
grammar schools that anti-meritocratic
Revolution
happened but it began to run out of
steam a bit Mrs Thatcher pushed back
against it by saying that we need
meritocracy but the the the ideal
vehicle of meritocracy is the market
rather than the state
um and Tony Blair to some extent new
labor pushed back against it by
accepting League tables and academic
schools but now what we have is another
big push against meritocracy this time
it's being done in the name of woke
rather than in the name of
uh quality comprehensive schools
egalitarianism but it's much more
serious this time than it was last time
because it presents an alternative
hierarchy uh to the world and that
hierarchy is a hierarchy of virtue
rather than the hierarchy of
um Robin equality and what this
hierarchy does is to reinvent the
pre-modern world uh in some ways to say
that we should judge people on the basis
of their group identities this is the
right way to be looking at the world
um but we must invert the old pyramid
that oppressed groups should be judged
to be virtuous uh in the way that the
old ruling class was just to be virtuous
and that we must get it get rid of this
idea of judging people on individual
merits because it's a deceit it's a lie
it's a way of perpetuating uh privilege
so this is once once a sort of more
vigorous attack on meritocracy and an
assertion of a different way of
organizing the world organizing the
world according to according to Virtue
as conceived by by the worker leads
rather than individual marriage in other
words it's the most significant attack
we've seen on the liberal idea I think
in my lifetime Peter let's break down
this concept of meritocracy a little bit
it's quite popular to say these days
that meritocracy doesn't really exist
but hard work doesn't get you anywhere
what do you make of the concept of
meritocracy do you think one exists in
the UK I'm sure concept existed but I
think a fact is has probably always
existed naturally in the intelligent
Society tends towards a certain amount
of meritocracy any society which ignores
the existence of talent in its midst and
doesn't and doesn't bring it on and and
make the maximum use of it as a foolish
Society I think a lot of occasions
during our history when we have overcome
snobbery and all kinds of other barriers
and said to people they should be
promoted on their merits I'm not sure
the left by the way was trying to to
attack meritocracy when it when it
attacked Ground Schools particularly the
Michael Young's book on the rise of the
meritocracy was was his own quirky view
that muratoxy would lead to some hideous
Society where people resented the
Justice of the position they found
themselves in I don't think most people
ever felt that the the left foolishly
believed that by opening up certificates
to everybody they opened up the
knowledge they thought to go with them
to everybody and so we have a society of
of huge numbers of certificates and very
little knowledge which is is probably
not what they intended but it is what
they got
Adrian can you talk us through how you
think this latest wave started and why
you think it's arguably more intense
than previous waves well it started in
American Academia in many ways um in the
1990s with the development of of of
critical race Theory and new waves of
feminism
um and the the unique thing about these
ideas is that they started off with the
belief that judging people as
individuals and embracing the idea of
meritocracy
um is a delusion because individuals are
caught up in a web of relations which um
which are more important than their
individual qualities and because Society
is structurally unjust so the only way
to get about this is not to give in to
this Bourgeois ideal of meritocracy but
to look at these structural
um problems and overcome them through
group Collective action rather than
individual action so it was it was a
university idea that's very strangely
has permeated the whole of society and
particularly it's made this strange
transition from quite radical University
departments uh or in some ways what
seemed like when Marshall University
developments to the heart of the
corporation through human resource
departments
um and human resource most corporations
now particularly in the United States
but spreading right right across the
world are committed to something called
Dei diversity equity and inclusion and
this word Equity is an extraordinarily
powerful word because it says that what
we should be aiming at in business is
not a quality of opportunity which is
the old meritocratic ideal but in some
ways the quality of results and some
strange people believe in the quality of
results but it's a very radical
reinterpretation of what Society should
be about and one of the strangest things
that's happened is that a lot of
radicals have come to the conclusion
that the best way to pursue their ends
is not by overturning capitalism but by
transforming capitalism from within
capturing things like uh like human
resource departments and working within
corporations to Define their ends in
very new ways Peter Adrian mentions
academics there and University campuses
where he thinks it started to Bubble Up
in his piece he talks about Cambridge
academic priyamvada gopal who has said
things like abolish whiteness what do
you make of this I mean should we really
be too worried about some Rogue comments
that are said from academics on
University campuses well it does seem to
spread quite quickly out of the
universities doesn't it so we should
worry about it because it obviously has
an appeal I think the appeal it has is
the one which Adrian mentioned in the
beginning the people virtue that we live
in a society where the the old concepts
of virtue which were based on
Christianity have more or less died away
it's not it's not known or understood as
a religion or as a set of principles or
as a moral system by millions of people
who find themselves even so craving as I
think almost everybody does for some
sort of guidance as to how to be good
and here here we have a whole new set of
beliefs which provides a set of guidance
in how to be good and it's
unrecognizable and mysterious to me
because I grew up in a different one but
I think we have to understand that
fundamentally it's it's it's however
much damage it does it's born on on the
wings of a desire which most of us can
understand as reasonable the problem is
it's wrong that they've not got they've
not got it right but they've become
obsessed with with climate change
they've become obsessed with sexual
politics and they've also become
obsessed and this I think is the result
of a definite campaign rather than a
collapse of of the Christian religion
they've become obsessed with with
getting rid of the patriarchy end of uh
of actually making a profound and final
attack on what we used to view as the
family I think the real sufferer in all
this is the family and the real gainer
in the end will be the state but as with
so many disastrous developments in
modern civilization it's based on a on a
benevolent wish but unfortunately the
benevolent wish will not turn out to to
be as benevolent in practice as it was
in theory and Adrian a new cover piece
you add another element to this and you
say it's one of the biggest aspects of
this new attack on meritocracy and that
of course is race what do you think has
changed in our conversations in the West
about race over these past few years I
think what's happened with with the the
this new this version of work that we
now have is that race has become much
more Central they've sort of thrown race
into the very center of these things
um and they've added to throwing race
into the center of these things a sort
of Deceit because the notion is that the
problems the very real problems of
racial inequality can only be solved
through Collective action and through
the identification of of people with
their their racial identity rather than
with any any other sort of identity I
would say that within the meritocratic
framework we had already taken very
significant steps towards
um removing
um barriers to uh ethnic minorities
um for being successful you know in this
country we have many members of the of
ethnic minorities in the cabinet many
members of ethnic minority is doing
extremely well at school perhaps the
most successful School in the country is
the Brampton Manor Academy in uh in East
London
um so we were through meritocracy
um
addressing uh long-term inequalities of
opportunity but what the the won't do is
to say that that's an impossibility you
can't do that that the meritocracy is
inherently racist it's saturated with uh
with with racism and the only way to
overcome Injustice is not to not to look
at individual ability or individual
efforts but to have Collective uh
categories Collective struggles and a
collective focus on these hidden forces
of racism which are which are everywhere
in societies so they have as well
they've come in at a time when when when
you know people have never been Freer
certainly in in advanced countries of of
racial
Prejudice and said no no no no you're
wrong you're not free you're absolutely
all of these things are very deeply
involved in what you think what you do
in society and it's only through a
process of collective action
um doing the work that we can solve
these problems Peter one of the things I
found really interesting about Adrian's
cover piece is that he doesn't let the
right off the hook he talks about the
right's own assault on meritocracy
calling it the form of populist rage
rather than high Tory worry about social
Mobility what do you make of that do you
think the right is just as complicit in
this attack well there isn't really a
right left is that
themselves to be on the right who are in
many cases just Market liberals who have
no real social theory at all who've long
ago Left Behind the precepts of
Christianity who aren't socially or
morally particularly conservative and
who are happy for society to be
extremely relaxed on those on those
matters and so they haven't really got
an argument half the problem with the
supposed rice in this country is that it
has long ago accepted or failed to
challenge and therefore come to live
with the things which the left had been
demanding particularly in the in the
areas of sexual politics and of the
again the the strength and importance of
the of the married family they've just
given in they have nothing particular to
say except let's have more let's let's
have more markets let's have more free
trade how is how is this any kind of
answer to the enormous if slightly
confused and in some cases bizarre moral
array of the new of the new left which
we've faced you're describing the class
wing of the Tory party which I would
argue has really actually dwindled over
the years but that's that's One Wing of
course there's another Wing which I
think atrian is referring to although he
can jump in here and correct me if I'm
wrong which does to have that more
populous take actually they might be
more economically liberal more socially
conservative but crucially are quite
happy to engage in the culture wars
well I I don't see much trace of it
honesty I don't think that the the
occasional Jordan Peterson Outburst
makes much difference to the enormous
preponderance of the other point of view
particularly on campuses or has really
much of an answer to it if you if you
didn't fight as the as the conservative
parties of the of the western Nations
did not fight the cultural and moral
Wars of the 1950s and 1960s you haven't
got much left to say when this when when
we arrive at this stage because you've
given in over so many of the earlier
battles that you really have no position
from which to stand I think there's
maybe there's a realization which I I
think everybody who's on the
conservative side of society needs to
make that we've lost and that there's
very little chance of giving anything
back and that is probably the only
realistic position to take but the
reasons why we lost was a lion in
battles long ago I would say that really
and truly if you wanted to combat these
developments you needed to come them
back in the in the late 1950s and early
1960s when the other side were thinking
very hard about them indeed people like
Roy Jenkins and Natalie crosstons begin
with and then after that the the
theorists who brought us to what what is
what became called political correctness
a huge revolution in the way we behaved
and organized our society which the
supposed right had no answer to except
more Market Adrian is interesting to me
in your piece that you say that the
conservatives essentially should feel
shame for the rise of the woke
eratocracy under their control I mean in
this country they have been in power for
well over a decade
uh absolutely I would say I would say
about the populist right I think the
populist writers is a very significant
Force primarily in the United States
this sort of Jacksonian tradition uh
that is embodied by by Trump and that's
a uh uh as a populist sentiment which is
really against Elites of various sorts
but particularly against the sort of the
pointy headed Elites of universities and
and bureaucracies and we see elements of
that in the in the conservative part
party here that's uh you know the the
the Nadine Doris talking about Posh boys
who don't know the price of milk and uh
and and all the rest of it these are
they're saying that these people are out
of touch with the the common people and
their great Common Sense uh and that
they're somehow
um deluded people I think brexit was a
manifestation of that sort of populist
anger against Trump uh obviously so I
think in the question of the
um
the fight against wokery and the
laziness of the conservative party I
think wokery is the wrong answer to some
real questions uh the real questions are
why are certain groups in this country
um trapped in poverty why do other
groups continue to dominate uh society
and continue to get an unfair share of
the rewards of that society and I think
there are certain answers to that
question which can be delivered by
looking at the meritocratic tradition
and modifying it improving it for for
for the modern world I think the
Brampton Manor Academy various
academically selective schools that try
and reach out to poorer people are
examples of that but we haven't pushed
far enough on that we've talked about
leveling up but we haven't talked
anything
like enough about spreading Excellence
throughout the country and increasing
opportunities about the country and so
workers
has a risen party as Peter has said as a
way of slaking our our appetite for for
virtue but partly as incorrect solutions
to very very real uh problems and I
think that we have to try harder not
only to address these problems but uh
you know almost a crow that we are
addressing uh addressing them or we will
have the workers doing what what I think
they're doing which is to smuggle in a
pre-modern way of thinking about the
world into into into modernity a pretty
liberal way of looking at the world
which I think is profoundly unhelpful
Peter and Adrian thanks for joining me
[Music]
thank you